liam hemsworth joins Miley Cyrus on  Saturday Night Live and it's the cutest  it's me brother the Aussie actor made a  surprise appearance on the sketch comedy  show over the weekend to support his  fiance who was the musical guest  alongside host Larry David  ladies and gentlemen Miley Cyrus during  a Price is Right sketch the 24 year old  singer played an audience member who was  paired with a celebrity contestant  Liam's a big bro Chris Hemsworth played  by cast member Alex Muffet you're really  cute yeah sorry love I'm married do you  have a brother  later the actor joined by Lee and Alex  when they phoned a friend  we've been hundred-and-fifty crocodile  take the board if you can and if that  wasn't cute enough Liam also stood  alongside his leading lady during the  closing vows thanks to Miley Cyrus Alec  Baldwin  you